you did soaps you were on passions yeah
and I thought like okay this is
interesting you probably could have
helped me out before I went and did a
soap all the tricks of the trade yeah
because they say there's it's like being
on bootcamp right when you're when
you're in a soap opera you have to train
so much
you're constantly performing that you
learn a lot well you learn the wrong
things so you you learn what not to do
later on in your career like I I moved
my face a lot when I was on passions I
moved your face a lot I did a lot of
face moving right which apparently for a
human woman is not it's not attractive
on camera on camera probably not exactly
for anybody to move their face too much
I mean why you were doing scenes yes
just do a lot of that like we do yeah
yeah so that's it you were
self-conscious and you were trying too
hard no I was just being a normal human
lady oh and apparently it's not it's no
one wants to see that people want to see
less people want to see people want to
see you talk like this
right yeah very stoic or you can get
also lost in a flashback loss camouflage
flashback face in your hopes your
remembering yeah they do a lot of
flashbacks and then you have to have you
have a special camera where you put on
your flashback face and there's always
fear of getting lost in the flashback
and never coming back so a flashback
would be like you would look to that
camera and you would start to remember
the times that you and then you just get
you just get lost in a reverie kind I
never got lost in the flashback I don't
know what would happen but I've heard
that people get lost in flashbacks and
they never come back
you know I'm freaking out I'm having a
flashback to Marty's flashback minute
that's a guy that's a guy
[Applause]
party that's a guy ledgering himself on
the subway another bad flashback we
we've had a picture of you from passion
oh good I'm sorry you are an
extraordinarily beautiful woman and they
put you in this pantsuit what was that
all about the famous blue pantsuit I
don't know they what they wanted me to
be a 75 year old accountant I guess and
I was 24 right right why they went out
of their way to make you look
middle-aged when you were 24 yeah we i
actually that pantsuit is very famous
because my my husband and i through a
film festival a few years ago called the
embarrassing film festival where we had
all of our actor friends submit their
worst works and we gave we gave prizes
what's such a really fun idea we had
some award-winning actors than the bunch
of really good names but I ended up
winning worst wardrobe with that and I
think worse hair and after they showed
that clip there were people there who
had known me for decades like good
friends good friends I had known for a
while and my husband overheard people
talking outside they were like did
Natalie just have a [ __ ] ton of work
done because she looks a hundred in that
these are these are your friend who's
known me for years okay yeah that's nice
yeah they're all sweeties
so actors
you